ضيفي هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه وكذلك من الخليل الدكتور بلال
الشوبكي رئيس قسم العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه الخليل اهلا بكم ابدا معك دكتور
خليل عندما نشاهد هذه المجزره الاخرى في
الخليل علينا ان نصدق اذا نتنياهو عندما
يقول لا تصدقوا بان واشنطن تضغط علينا كما
قال في اخر تصريح له هذا اليوم هذا صحيح
عبد القادر نحن ازء نمط من الاجرام
الاسرائيلي مستمر على مدار اكثر من شهرين
8 يوم النهارده حسب بعض الاحصاءات على
الاقل تم ارتكاب 1720 مجزره داخل قطاع غزه
معظمها طبعا لاطفال لمدنيين لنازحين من
اماكن القتال الى حد بعيد ده ياتي في اطار
تزامن مع عده امور الامر الاول هو على ما
يبدو ان هناك محوله للانتقام من سقوط
ضحايا في الجيش الاسرائيلي سواء كانوا
قتلى او مصابين نتكلم النهارده فيخر 24
ساعه عدد كبير جدا سواء قتل او مصابين فده
نوع من الانتقام من المدنيين الفلسطينيين
الامر الثاني مطبط كما تفضلت واشرت على ما
يبدو وجود او استمرار الضوء الاخضر
الامريكي لنتنياهو كان يستمر في هذه الحرب
الهمجيه على عكس ما يدعيه بايدن حول حمايه
المدنيين نحن اذاء تناقض سياسي واخلاقي
وقيمي امريكي يقوم على اولا من جهه حديث
متواصل حول حمايه المدنيين وفي نفس الوقت
اعطاء ضوء اخضر لاسرائيل من جهه وايضا
مدها بالسلاح لا استبعد انه من قتل اليوم
قتلوا بسلاح امريكي سواء قنابل بنتكلم على
الاقل تم مد اسرائيل على الاقل 57 الف
قنبله على الاقل الاف الصواريخ المجنحه
نتكلم على جسر جوي عسكري امريكي على مدار
اكثر من شهرين فبنت على شراكه امريكيه
كامله في هذا القتل في المقابل حديث فقط
لمجرد حفظ ماء الوجه حول حفظ حياه
المدنيين حول حمايتهم شكل او باخر حول
تقديم مساعده انسانيه لهم وبالتالي نحن
اذاء معضله امريكيه اخلاقيه
وقيم نش نجي على الارض وجزء رئيس من هؤلاء
الضحايا هم ضحايا لامريكا ويس فقط
لاسرائيل دكتور بلاد بك يا ضيفي من الخليل
عندما ايضا نشاهد ايضا هذه المجزره وهذه
الصور وهذه الشهادات ال القاتله اقل ما
يمكن ان يوصف توصف بها ما شاهدناه وهذا
الحوار الذي كان بين هذا الطفل وولي امره
الذي كان معه صوره قاتله يصعب
التعبير عنها هنا اسال عن الحسابات
الاسرائيليه في تكرار ذات السيناريو منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب ويبدو ان هناك نيه مره
اخرى هذه المره لتنفيذ اكثر من مجزره
تحديدا ما يجري في هذه الليله في وسط قطاع
غزه ماذا عن الحسابات
الاسرائيليه هناك عده اهداف تحاول اسرائيل
تحقيقها من مثل هذه العمليات يعني هي جزء
منها اولا ما تحدثنا عنه في بدايه هذه
الحرب انها تصرفت بطريقه انتقاميه من
الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه على اعتبار ان
المسؤول عن ما جرى في السابع من اكتوبر
ليس فقط حركه حماس وانما الكل الفلسطيني
الذي احتضن هذه الحركه وهذا بالمناسبه هذا
خطاب كان سائد حتى فتره طويله وحتى هذه
اللحظه يعني يحظى ب مقبولي لدى اوساط
كثيره لدى المجتمع الاسرائيلي لانه كل
الفلسطينيين هم مسؤولين عن ما جرى في
السابع من اكتوبر وبالتالي يتوجب ان يتوجه
العقاب للكل الفلسطيني المساله الثانيه هي
تامل المؤسسه العسكريه والامنيه
الاسرائيليه وعلى راسهم بيمين نتنياهو في
مجلس الحرب انه مثل هذه العمليات ربما
تفضي الى تاليب الراي العام الفلسطيني ضد
المقاومه الفلسطينيه هناك محاوله لتح ك
هذا الموضوع ليس فقط من خلال العمليه
العسكريه المباشره وانما من خلال بث رسائل
وايصالها احيانا وصل الامر الى رمي
منشورات من طائرات مسيره على الفلسطينيين
سواء في قطاع غزه او في الضفه الغربيه
تحذرهم من يعني ضنك العيش نتاجا لدعم
حركات المقاومه الفلسطينيه وبالتالي السعي
الاسرائيلي دائما كان قائم من اجل يعني
تقويض الحاضن الجماهيريه للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه بالاضافه الى بعد اخر وهو
ينبغي دائما الاشاره اليه انه كل ما كلما
تم استهداف المدنيين هذا يؤكد على ان
اسرائيل ماضيه قدما في مشاريعها من اجل
احداث تغييرات ديموغرافيه وجغرافيه داخل
قطاع غزه وربما تنتقل في مراحل اخرى الى
مناطق اخرى في الاراضي الفلسطينيه لذلك
الاستمرار في هذه العمليات يعني يحقق عده
اهداف من من منظور اسرائيلي ويعبر ايضا عن
فشل اسرائيل في تقديم يعني اهداف للمجتمع
الاسرائيلي اهداف ذات قيمه استراتيجيه على
المدى البعيد لانه كلما اشير هذه كلما
اشرت اليه ه هكذا يفكر الاسرائيليون لكن
ليس بالضروره ان هذا ما سيجري بمعنى انه
تجارب الفلسطينيين مع استهداف المدنيين
واستهداف البنيه التحتيه والمنشات المدنيه
لم يؤثر على التفاف التفافهم حول المقاومه
وحول الفصائل الفلسطينيه هذا حصل خل
الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه الثانيه ما وصفته
باستهداف الحاضنه الشعبيه يحيلني الى ما
طرحه قبل قليل الزميل وائل الدحدوح اكثر
من مره نقلا على السنه الناس كالذي جرى في
مخيم البريج يطلب من الناس الخروج من هذه
الاماكن من قبل جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وعندما يهمون بالخروج يستهدف هؤلاء
النازحون وهذا جرى في اكثر من مره خلال
الشهرين الماضيين وبالتالي انت تؤكد انه
الاستهداف لاجل الاستهداف معنى ان استهداف
المدنيين هو سياسه او جزء من هذه الحرب
الاسرائيليه نعم هي ليست اعراض جانبيه
الحرب الاسرائيليه على الفصائل الفلسطينيه
يعني منذ اللحظات الاولى كان واضح ان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يستهدف كل قطاع غزه
بكل ما في قطاع غزه و ومن بين الاهداف
التي قد تظهر خلال العمليه العسكريه هي
استهداف الفصائل الفلسطينيه بمعنى انه
منطق بنيمين نتنياهو ومجلس الحرب منذ
الاسابيع الاولى لهذه الحرب لم يكن لديهم
اهداف واضحه الشعارات التي اطلقت في بدايه
الحرب عن تحقيق انتصار وتقويض حركه حماس
وما الى ذلك من امور هم اول من يعلم ان
هذه اهداف غير غير قابله للتحقق ليس لان
هذه الفصائل الفلسطينيه يعني تمتلك مقدرات
عظيمه جدا و انما لان هذه الفصائل
الفلسطينيه بنيتها وطبيعه تشكيلها غير
مرتبطه بمقدراتها العسكريه ولو كان الامر
مرتبط بالمقدرات العسكريه لما شاهدنا انه
حتى هذه اللحظه حركه حماس ما زالت موجوده
في اماكن اخرى غير قطاع غزه وحمله
الاعتقالات التي شنتها اسرائيل في الاونه
الاخيره تشير الى انه كل محاولات الاجت
التي مرست في الطف الغربيه لم تفضي الى
شيء وبالتالي الاستهداف هو للكل الفلسطيني
والهدف يعني متعدد الجوانب مرتبط بالواقع
الاني بمعنى رد فعل يعني انتقامي على ما
جرى في السابع من اكتوبر بالاضافه الى
اهداف اخرى مرتبطه بكيفيه تفكير
الاسرائيليين بمعنى انهم يتعاملوا معنا مع
الفلسطينيين بذات المنطق الذي يفكر به
الاسرائيلي يعني الان ما يدور في الاوساط
الاسرائيليه ان هناك شريحه من المجتمع
الاسرائيلي بدات تغير رايها وموقفها من
الحرب نتاج لما باتت تدفع من اثمان على
المستوى الاقتصادي وعلى مستوى الخسائر
البشريه هم يفكروا بذات الطريقه ان
الفلسطينيين ربما يعني يكون تفاعلهم مع
الحرب بذات النهج دكتور خليل في الايام
الاولى للحرب او حتى في الشهر الاول من
هذه الحرب كان يقال ان هناك ضوء اخضر غير
معلم حتى تقوم اسرائيل لمده ما حتى ولو
على هذا الامر تنفيذ مجازر كبيره كالذي
حدث في هذه الحرب نحن نكاد نتم الشهر
الثالث في هذه الحرب هل مازال هذا الضوء
الاخضر مفتوح بلا اجل ايضا اعود واذكر مره
اخرى بتصريحات نيتنياهو بالقول نحن دوله
ذات سياده ونملك قرارنا ماذا عن الضغوط
الدوليه يعني بشكل عام ليس هناك احترام
لهذه الضغوط عبد القادر بنتكلم على عدم
اكتراث على الاطلاق بالقانون الدولي عدم
اكتراث بجود ضغوط دوليه حتى عندما تحدث
بايدن قبل اسبوعين وقال وصرح ولمح بشكل او
اخر ان هناك نوع من عدم الارتياح لنتنياهو
والمطالبه بتغييره قامت الدنيا لم ت تقعد
بالعكس تم تحدي بايدن تم المدير قدم فه
هذيه المجازر بنتكلم على ساسه عقاب جماعي
لفلسطينيين وهذا جزء رئيسي ممنهج من
اسرائيل في فيما تقوم به الان في قطاع غزه
متعلق بالعقاب الجماعي لفلسطينيين بمحاوله
تهجيرهم باتجاه الجنوب ومن ثم باتجاه مصر
وبالتالي الموقف الامريكي الى حد بعيد
موقف ضعيف مهتز وجزء من جرءه اسرائيل
فهمها لهذا الضعف وهذا الاهتزاز بمعنى اخر
ليس هناك حتى الان ضغط امريكي مصحوب
بادوات حقيقيه اولا
لمعاقبه اسرائيل على جرائمها ثانيا لوضع
شروط على المساعده العسكريه بنتكلم على
دعم عسكري كما قلت غير محدود لم يتم
الحديث على الاطلاق على وجود شروط على هذه
الاسلحه شروط من قبل مثلا او من قبيل عدم
استهداف مدنيين عدم استخدامها في مناطق
للمدنيين عدم استخدام ممرات امنه يعني
بنتكلم على اعطاء تحذيرات بالتحرك ثم ضرب
ه المتحركين هذا نمط اسرائيلي رايناه في
استهداف منازل مدارس مساجد كنائس عربيات
اسعاف وحتى مسعفين وحتى الدفاع المدني
فنتكلم على عدم اكتراث اسرائيلي باي ضغط
امريكي هناك رهان عن هذه الاداره اداره
ضعيفه مهتزه وقلت اكثر من مره اداره
مختطفه من قبل نتنياهو لصالح مشروع
السياسي على حساب مشروع بايدن حتى داخل
امريكا